merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous connaissez déjà tout à la
suite de neuf jours de grève et chacun a
pu constater qu'il soit parisien
d'occasion ou parisiens d'habitude
l'amour seulement dans certains
arrondissements de Paris à saint-ombre
de poubelle que vous avez qualifié vous
de plusieurs milliers de tonnes posent
des questions pour la sécurité
évidemment de nos concitoyens ou même
d'ailleurs où il y a des manifestations
mais pose aussi des questions de
salubrité publique que chacun peut
constater et pour avoir été comme
beaucoup ici gestionnaire d'une
connectivité locale chacun peut voir ce
que c'est qu'attendre 9 jours et voir
des milliers de tonnes d'ordures et de
poubelles effectivement être sur la voie
publique j'ai donc demandé mais au nom
de la salubrité publique puisque mise à
l'intérieur est en charge d'un tutelle
sur le préfet de police la préfecture de
police et après avoir contacté
évidemment Madame la Maire de Paris
après avoir été saisi vous avez évoqué
Madame Dati en effet par plusieurs
maires d'arrondissements mais aussi par
plusieurs élus parisiens quel que soit
leur bord politique après avoir été
saisi par eux j'ai donc demandé à Madame
Hidalgo d'abord évidemment à l'oral et
ensuite ce matin par la terminale préfet
de police par écrit de pouvoir faire ce
que le droit lui permet de faire
notamment que la mairie de Paris a fait
pendant 10 de la loi travail puisque
déjà eu effectivement une situation
similaire de réquisitionner la question
qui relève à la fois du relèvement du
des poubelles qui sont relevées pardon
de l'espace public comme de
l'incinération parce qu'il s'agit bien
des deux sujets à l'oral j'ai entendu en
effet ce matin le premier adjoint évoqué
le fait qu'il ne serait pas favorable à
cette situation j'attends évidemment que
Madame la Maire de Paris réponde par
écrit à la demande par écrit du préfet
de police et si ce soir cette
confirmation a été faite la mairie de
Paris ne prenait pas ses responsabilités
je le dis ce soir demain matin au plus
tard le préfet de police propose
possédera réquisition au nom de la
salubrité publique et je crois que tous
les parisiens quel que soit ce qu'ils
pensent de la réforme des retraites en
seront heureux
[Musique]